well Emma Thompson clever funny mad as a
chair
that's true you know him yes In fairness
yeah I'm quite a mad chair
Randy's alberger delightful all so far
from sane
fair
then we get into a run of these Julianne
Moore brilliant actress loads me
yes Rachel Vice clever beautiful
despises me yes Drew Barrymore made her
cry hates me
um Julian definitely hates me
future wise I think we got on fire I
don't know why I said that maybe I was
going for a comedy triple I don't know
who was the third one uh Drew Barrymore
she made the mistake of giving me notes
which how would you take that when
you're acting with someone else very
well didn't I